en classe dans l'autre but de didier
drogba une autre bière à la santé des
succès de l'impact à chaque match au
stade saputo
environ 8000 consommation finissent dans
le gosier des partisans selon des
chercheurs de l'université du minnesota
la moitié des spectateurs à un événement
sportif se retrouve avec un verre à la
main
18 35 ans aux mêmes neuf fois plus de
risque de quitter un match en état
d'ébriété 0,08 là c'est rien du genre
s'abstraire on sais pas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire finalement là ça fait plaisir
d'avoir des petitesses 900 qu'elle soit
qu'on apprenne à à jauger avec le temps
l'impact n'a pas hésité à embrasser le
projet d'alcon prévention il y a deux
mois
le club est devenu le premier au pays à
éduquer sa clientèle sur les dangers de
l'alcool a testé ses partisans rond
comme un ballon et à leur offrir un
service de raccompagnement
on n'est pas habitué de voir ce genre de
service là dans un stade je dirais même
les gens font appel à ce genre de
service cependant les temps des fight et
apprécié on en entend plus vraiment
parler
le principe est simple vous célébrez
vous buvez vous souffler et moyennant
quelques dollars
des chauffeurs vous ramène à la maison
vous et votre voiture et client doit
payer seulement l'accompagnement donc et
yoko d'heure aucun membre chip qui doit
être pays
j'ai 1 35 dollar sur l'île de montréal
45 qu'à l'extérieur
sur les 150 personnes par match testé
deux ont utilisé cette opération nez
rouge à la sauce au caire dans sept
douze mille temps des papiers de bureau
tournoi de golf et 40% des gens qu'on de
tester était au dessus des limites 2.08
et de ce 40 % leur la moitié ne s'en
doutait pas alko prévention négocier
avec des clubs de baseball de acquis et
de football à montréal et à toronto afin
d'étendre cette expérience qui pourrait
bien devenir la norme en 2016 dans nos
stades
ici jean patrick ballu radio canada
montréal